if you are waiting for your new home to
be built you could be waiting a lot
longer than you might be expecting
supply shortages are causing delays in
the home building industry and as joe
moeller explains these delays could be
getting worse
people can be waiting an extra few weeks
to an extra few months these delays are
not only creating headaches for home
buyers but also home builders back in
june
they were told six months cindy
coaster's parents are building a new
home in mesquite end of july and it went
to eight months and now they're running
eight to ten months her family like many
others are facing delay after delay
right now they're
living in an airbnb which is costing
them a fortune these delays with
construction are happening to just about
every home builder windows plastics
appliances you name it garage doors i
mean garage doors
we're trying to finish people's houses
and we can't move mints we don't have a
garage door nat hodgins from the
southern nevada home builders
association says a lot of materials come
from overseas and are stuck on ships of
the port this means move-in dates are
getting pushed back and home buyers are
looking for places to live in a rental
market that is already tough we have
quite a few california buyers they've
sold it they've come out here they're
getting ready to close in their house
here with a date
and you know the house is done except
for a couple
things of material missing hodgson says
this is pushing some builders to ask
building departments to allow some
buyers to move into their homes that are
not finished yet the issue won't fix
itself overnight and he says it could
get worse over the next two months when
we fix the port issue then you have to
get the product from the port
on the trucks if you plan to build a new
home anytime in the near future industry
experts do urge you to have a little bit
of flexibility on your move-in time
frame reporting in summerlin joe mohler
live local now
hodgson also suggests keeping in touch
with your home builder you're working
with as much as possible to get a heads
up on when a delay could be expected